هذه الطريقه على الحدود اللبنانيه السوريه
لن تبقى سالكه وسهله على شبكات التجار
بالمخدرات والتهريبها في المنطقه بعد ان
اقر الكونجرس الامريكي مشروع قرار يضع
استراتيجيه امريكيه لوقف انتاج المخدرات
والتجار بها وتفكيك الشبكات المرتبطه
بنظام الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
المرتبط بنظام الاسد يشكل تهديدا عابرا
للحدود ويدور بالامن البشري في الشرق
الاوسط
اما ابرز البنود التي تتضمنها
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه تكمن بتقديم الدعم
للحلفاء من دول المنطقه الذين يتلقون
كميات كبيره من الكابت جون خلال عمليات
تهريبها الى السعوديه والاردن المشروع
ايضا سيوظف نظام العقوبات بشكل فعال بما
فيها عقوبه قيصر لاستهداف شبكه المخدرات
التابعه لنظام السوري لكن ما هي خريطه
طريق مصانع المخدرات في سوريا
وايران والفرقه الرابعه التابعه لنظام
السوري تحولت محافظه درعا وقنيطره الى
مركز لارسال المخدرات تجاه الدول المجاوره
للحدود السوريه والخليج العربي
50 معمل للمخدرات في سوريا يقع معظمها في
مناطق نفوذ نظام الاسد وفق دراسه بمركز
جسور للدراسات